I want to begin by talking a little bit
about why international organization
seems to be left out of most of theories
that you've probably reading and
studying at the moment to me
international organization and
particularly the UN is really they're
homeless institutions when it comes to
IR theory frankly most of people who do
theory and most of people who write
about political science know very little
about international institutions and are
not terribly interested in learning much
more and most people who know about
international institutions frankly don't
know much about IR theory maybe they
should but they don't seem to be too
interested and so if there's a
conversation at all it tends to be a
dialogue of the of the death now to me
these institutions not only are homeless
in in theory but they're really quite
unsinkable in practice I won't sing the
praises of most international
institutions most the ones I know don't
work particularly well bureaucracies are
inefficient they're nothing compared to
Columbus Raptors of course but they are
quite inefficient and their delivery is
as sometimes thing they tend to be
relatively unaccountable the only group
I can think even less the kind of what
probably would be college professors who
are completely unaccountable but
nevertheless these are not institutions
I reported any pedestal in terms of
performance but it does seem despite
that that people keep coming back to
them again and again and again now not
only are realists dismissive of
international institutions which is
always convenient to dismiss the things
they don't know about and assume if you
don't know about things they must not
matter but of course the things are
really in the end get us are the things
that we haven't studied and don't know
about but not only the realists have a
problem with them but so do most
liberals and many idealists because to
them these institutions are continually
disappointing they're disappointing in
part
because they are based to a certain
extent not only on law and principle but
also on power those who only understand
power don't understand law in principle
and those are only understand law in
principle don't understand power and it
seems to me what we ought to be doing is
seeing how these come together and we
ought to take more realistic approaches
to international institutions now I was
asked just before we started about why
did I suggest the readings in the order
that I put them I put MercyMe here first
not only because he's a very
distinguished political scientist but
his arguments are the most easiest to
dismiss and so why not why not start
there they're particularly easy when
he's not in the room it's most most
convenient but it does seem to me he
begins with this assumption as do most
realists that because states create
international institutions and because
they largely control international
institutions then there's nothing
interesting to study in and of these
institutions they're simply the product
of national policy and therefore bring
very little to the argument now the Ian
herd piece suggests that there are some
pieces of sovereignty that these
institutions exercise because they do
have control over certain situations and
of course as the constructivist who
would argue they really do shape the
values that states do bring to foreign
policy very often now clearly those who
founded the UN were not simple-minded
idealist among them was Joe Stalin there
were people who obviously founded these
organizations for very hard-headed
reasons to advance national interest and
if they had not done so and if they not
had created that kind of structure we
probably wouldn't have them around today
but it does seem to me they are firmly
based in real politic they were not
created in a very simple meditation
session out in in San Francisco they
were in fact very very hard fought
battles over how these institutions
would work what the power relationships
would be both within each of the
principle organs and certainly
between them for the p5 who are the
conveners and then adding France later
clearly this is all about into the
future perpetuating a wartime alliance
it was to create an oligopoly oligopoly
of power and they wanted to keep this
going and they found a pretty good ways
a way to do it
but it does seem to me when you look at
some of the statements of the time they
meld rather nicely the sort of realistic
and the idealistic Edward Stettinius was
the u.s. foreign minister at the time he
was head of the US delegation this is
widely regretted he was someone who came
from a business background god forbid
someone who is known as being
particularly pedestrian in his thinking
and in his speech he and I have a lot in
common and people said my god you know
he's going to have no no sense of
leadership at all yeah but he said
something at the time of the Charter
which I I think is worth thinking about
a little bit he said the first function
of a Charter is moral and idealistic the
second realistic and practical men and
women who have lived through war are not
ashamed as other generations sometimes
are to declare the depth and the
idealism of their attachment to the
cause of peace but neither they ashamed
to recognize the realities of force and
power which war had forced them to see
and endure as I'll talk about in a
minute it is indeed war that tends to
produce international organization and
the bigger the war the bigger the
international organization now DAG
hammarskjöld
gave it much shorter and more famous
rendition of this in 1954 which I'm sure
most of you have heard when he said the
United Nations was not created in order
to bring us heaven but in order to save
us from hell if you work at the UN you
may not sure that's true now you may
think about the bureaucracy was to send
the international civil civil service to
hell but nevertheless that all depends
on one's definition I suppose now if you
look at the history of international
organization going back a few years you
look at the 30 Years War and they
Deewar which produced among other things
are treated Westphalia and the very
basis for the interstate system of
non-intervention and and the sense of
sovereignty which I'll talk about more
later and really that in essence
provides the basis of interstate
organization it also produces produced
Hugo Grotius ideas at 17th century Dutch
legal scholar unjust war doctrine and a
more tame kind of relationship among
states now this worked for a while and
then we had of course the Council of
Europe in the beginning of the 19th
century and a series of international
institutions were created most people
forget that the 19th century creation of
international institutions in some ways
was was in a functional way almost as
broad as what we see now not only do you
have the Council of Europe you have the
Elba and Ryan Commission's you had the
Universal Postal Union the International
Telecommunications Union oops that still
exists today were founded way back then
the inter-parliamentary Union again
still with us the ICRC and and some 30
very broad-based intergovernmental
organizations dealing with functional
kinds of issues in terms of stopping
disease around the world and various
Courage's you had dozens of
organizations created just in the 19th
century for that purpose alone and at
the end of the century you had the Hague
conferences in many ways putting
humanitarian law and arms control both
on the map a time we had major big bucks
people like Carnegie getting involved in
international affairs it's not only
today that you have this kind of
independent influence you had hundreds
of NGOs actively lobbying again it's not
only today that we have these kinds of
things and you had a degree of
interdependence in terms of trade that
is higher than we have today
so the theory was ok we work on league
arbitration we're working all these
functional agencies were work on trade
we're tied
in a way that they couldn't possibly go
to war and of course what happened we
had World War one so what did World War
One say okay we had all this
international organization we have all
this trade what did we get World War so
what do we need we need more
international organization maybe didn't
work the first time so we got the league
the league didn't work perfectly
wonderfully terrific set of functional
institutions a little less effective in
peace and security and so what do we get
we get World War 2 we get bigger
organization and then we get bigger Wars
and then after that we get still bigger
organizations and so what happens after
World War 2 you think it will despair
let's try something different
international law international
organization isn't working so what do
they do they create yet a larger more
ambitious organization in terms of the
UN the UN system and the Bretton Woods
institutions
people usually say they prefer iPhone in
the lectures it's much more pleasant
that way then you can sort of imagine
what the speaker is like and you know
it's a lot like it's not like
International Institute a lot of
feedback going on all the time you know
there's a lesson from all this never
question the realists they get back to
they always get back to you one way or
the other you know if you're
constructivist no one cares you know you
have no relationship to power if you're
a realist you know how to control things
so we've never never questioned the
realist
anyway if you if you recall before the
pleasant interruption I was talking
about these cycles you know you get more
than or organization that you work for
the more organization you know people
never learned and so you know the end of
the Cold War and so after the Cold War
whether you get a reinvigoration of
international institutions a huge surge
in peacekeeping in the early 90s you get
probably more creation of international
law during the decade of the 90s than at
any other point in human history and
then what happens then he had the war in
Iraq okay and the Secretary General
himself is treading that the
organization has become irrelevant the
big powers has gone and gone around the
Security Council and we're in big
trouble so what happens before you know
it big powers are back from the council
peacekeeping is going up again the
organization is being used more than
ever before now I'm a little afraid to
do this but I actually have a couple of
PowerPoint projections here
not quite sure what's going to happen
let's see hey okay we don't have sound
but we have a picture so what more could
we want okay if you look at the number
of Security Council resolutions and
presidential statements as you see the
basic trend Kenda's tendencies up up up
suggest the council is fairly is fairly
busy you look at the number of Security
Council meetings and consultations this
obviously is a fairly busy group you
look at the end of the Cold War with 55
formal meetings and 62 and formal
consultations you look now last year we
had almost 500 it's obviously more than
one meeting a day many meetings that the
council now had four or five different
issues going on at the same time and
this does not even count all those sort
of non meetings of the council where all
the real work happens because they
happen in various missions and little
informal informal Greek groupings where
even the informal consultation room is
too formal
so they go off in other places to do the
work so this is non-stop seven days a
week
pretty much 365 days a year
morning noon and very often night now
whether this is a good thing or not I'll
leave to you but clearly whoever says
the council is going out of business UN
is going out of business isn't watching
the numbers now I think we have 19
ongoing peace operations and I think if
you look at the number of mediation
state building kinds of exercises going
on
there's something like 40 now at the
present time they're more peacekeepers
deployed than ever by the UN which
doesn't count the number deployed by
NATO the AU and others you put them
together we probably have at least
200,000 military forces deployed not to
mention all the civilians and others to
go along with us
so obviously maybe this is not important
maybe it's irrelevant maybe can be
dismissed but it is happening now let me
talk a little bit about Mike Glennon why
do you put Michael in and second because
you know his good friend he's also easy
to
easy to critique I know if you both read
and memorized his beast but just in case
you didn't he suggested charter has gone
the way of the 1928 kellogg-briand pact
if you ever wanted to have some
entertaining reading go back and read
the Senate debate about the
kellogg-briand pact and the various
statements of the parties all the
parties basically said it would no way
inhibit their foreign policy or use of
military force nevertheless it was a
monumental break breakthrough for
international peace and security so I
thought was a good thing okay now he
goes on and very much
echoes coffee and on I'm not sure
whether coffee read his stuff or vice
versa saying the council is ruptured
it's failed and it will not be
resuscitated and the regime of the non
use of force has collapsed and basically
no longer no longer matters now going
back to Murray signer he argues I think
it's an interesting argument that it's
institutions have mattered rather little
historically and the what really is
worrisome is that people think that
international institutions matter
and he goes beyond that to say what's
really terrible is that Americans have a
particular weakness to believe that
international law and international
institutions matter and the realists
have proven that they don't and
therefore this could be very dangerous
for our foreign policy and an
understanding of the world now clearly
the American leadership either has read
MercyMe ER and agree that in fact
Americans are likely to fall into this
trap and they too have fallen into this
trap because if you look at the u.s.
activity in the Security Council and
elsewhere in the UN I would argue that
it's at an all-time high the u.s. is
more active trying to get more things
done in the council then than ever
before and what is striking is that it's
not just marginal questions let's say an
isolated conflict
part of Africa or another but in fact
the US is bringing its major
international security concerns to the
Security Council take the question of
Iran nuclear weapons Korea nuclear
weapons terrorism now it's not the same
that the US only uses a council
obviously it has a lot of other tools
but it keeps going back on things that
really are quite central to its to its
international security interests now it
could be argued that this is only
because it's a facade and that because
groups in the public care about these
institutions or have these silly
idealistic viewpoints that the leaders
are bending to this but it really
doesn't matter because they don't do
anything that really isn't importance
there and then I think one has to ask
why is it over the course of an
administration they become more and more
enamored of using the UN as an
institution
I remember in Ronald Reagan was was
president long before any of you were
born of course and I was at that time
the head of the United Nations
Association in this country and we were
a little worried because Congress had
said some years back we were supposed to
have a a UN Day celebration October 24th
I assume you all paused last week on
October 24th for UN day I assumed that
the whole place was draped in light blue
and it's convenient the Columbia light
blue and UN light blue are almost
identical and I assume the whole place
wasn't baked in black as when an addenda
job spoke here but anyway
nationally UN day were supposed to lead
the celebration around the country and
all the main mayor's the big cities and
all the governor's post upon you end a
chairman and of the 50 governors only
one refused to appoint a UN day chairman
he of course being Ronald Reagan in
California so we thought this was not a
promising start when he came to the UN
the first time after becoming president
but what is striking if you look at the
changing nature of both the u.s.
engagement to the UN over his tenure
his words on this annual trip to the
General Assembly his final speech is one
of the closest most personal tributes to
the UN that you're going to find that he
had looked forward every year to this
journey up to New York and speaking to
all of his friends in the assembly and
this was so important to the u.s. he he
also made the effort to start paying off
the dues some minor reforms were made in
the UN and he decided these were
earth-shaking and the whole UN had
turned around all of a sudden was it was
a hunky-dory body but we haven't seen
quite the same metamorphosis with george
w but he's certainly moved in that
direction a good deal from the days when
he was totally dismissive of the
organization and that was only
occasionally so so you know there does
seem to be something of a learning
process over time and if it was only a
facade
you wouldn't bring you major issues any
wouldn't overtime seem to have this kind
of a kind of a learning process now you
know I think the realists do have a
point
as I said beginning they they point out
that these institutions are run by
States and power matters a great deal
but what they fail to tell us is where
national interests come from who defines
national interests you know we wouldn't
have elections we wouldn't have debates
if in fact it was intuitively obvious
that there's a set of three for our
interest we know what the hierarchy is
and we know what to do about it even if
we agree on what the interests are it
doesn't tell us what kind of policy one
pursues to forward those interests and
it does seem to me that all of that
revolves a great deal around values
around values and perceptions and around
the consideration of what options we
might have and this I think very
importantly is where constructivism
comes in it's where Martha Finney Mars
piece comes in and where humanitarian
and human rights issues enter into the
into the fray now I'd like to say a few
words about the Security Council it's
actually quite a few words now as I
pointed out the council is very active
whether it whether the council is a
effective or not I leave it to you to
think about but it is worth looking at
the human security report and I hope you
read that one at least or the summary of
it because it is very short and simple
it's worth remembering that whatever the
problems are in the world then in fact
there's been enormous amount of progress
the number of wars between states down
strikingly since the end of the Cold War
the number of wars within States down
the number of casualties from war again
down the number of refugees down a lot
now the number of internally displaced
people a little harder to tell but at
least doesn't appear to be going up
dramatically despite problems in various
places I was in Bogota over the weekend
and talking to human rights and and
refugee people for the UN and you know
they have the second largest group of
IDPs in the world obviously there are
spots where the problems have not gone
away but overall the trend lines are
very encouraging just as most of the
economic trend lines are relatively
encouraging with rates of economic
growth up much more rapidly in
developing than developed countries with
infant mortality down with life
expectancy up with the number of people
in in total poverty down quite
considerably far higher than when ever
would want but the overall trend lines
are going in the right direction so
there might actually be some evidence
that international institutions might be
be helping a bit at least in the
aggregate now there's five problems I'd
like to to point out with the council
that is sort of worrisome because let's
say that it's true that there is this
basic urge for multilateral cooperation
there is this tendency among even
policymakers to learn over time and try
to use international institutions more
are these institutions actually ready
are they capable can they absorb all the
new business that they're getting and
there's five worries I'd like to talk
about a little bit now
one is the range of issues being
undertaken by the council now this is a
chart I did up a couple years ago for a
book that Michael Doyle and I did on
compliance with international law and I
put four there a little mini theory not
only about compliance but the commitment
to ensuring compliance to international
law and the argument is basically that
you know law is not law is not law and
that the international environment is so
different than domestic ones the
analogies don't work very well
back and forth now it seemed to me if
you looked at various spheres of
international law and activity you could
roughly put them in three large clusters
one where there's a rather low
commitment to compliance and enforcement
are those dealing with human interests
naturally things like human rights
humanitarian concerns democratic
practices and the like in the middle are
sort of transnational interests those in
which everyone is responsible and so no
one is responsible and where you have
obviously fundamental questions of who's
going to take the burden and who's going
to take the lead environment global
Commons issues like health narcotics
crime and local conflict conflict in
which the major powers don't have a deep
interest and I'd include in that things
like land mines and small arms like
weapons efforts at reduction things that
are not going to fundamentally affect
the overall strategic balance in any
particular way so these are the areas
actually where the UN tends to be deeply
involved as well as many of those on the
left side of the chart on human
interests and then you get to those on
on the right side the core national
interests and there I put physical
security things like you know WMD
aggression terrorism and importantly
trade issues trade finance economic
prosperity the things that either win or
lose votes and therefore matter or that
have to do with with national security
and national survival now what you end
up seeing in terms of compliance
mechanisms on the Left you have a lot of
monitoring fact-finding reporting some
incentives some efforts of capacity
building public diplomacy very little in
terms of sanctions negative kinds of
kinds of enforcement and most of
responses tend to be rather ad hoc by
States okay in the middle the compliance
mechanisms tend to be very articulated
quite quite ambitious but they're very
heavily dependent on cooperative
mechanisms of one sort or another which
is where the UN tends to come come into
again the tools monitoring fact-finding
reporting capacity building judicial
processes and some incentives and the
like and a big role for private
organizations NGOs and whatever but what
you end up seeing in those treaties very
big sections on compliance and
verification a lot of mechanisms a lot
of bureaucracies and rather little
national power and effort behind them so
let's leave it to the UN let's leave it
to the International Organization to do
something about it and you go on the
right the core national interests those
tend to be very heavily dependent on
reciprocity on power I would include the
WTO in that certainly most arms control
east of an east-west variety and rather
little articulation of institutional
formats because you don't need it
because you have the power to deal with
it instead and now looking at the bottom
very different domestic constituencies
human interests broad but thin advocacy
groups but somewhere else skeptics as
well who sort of pull it down in the
middle very broad constituencies and
very well
focused advocacy NGOs epistemic
communities and the like but probably
big splits in Parliament's and and quite
different viewpoints as whether they are
in the national interest or not and then
on the right you tend to have a general
consensus nationally and those 10
Columbia University are in the small
minority who descent and the rest of the
country tends to be more supportive and
the dissenters probably feel they pay a
price in terms of their dissent okay now
why did I raise all of this other than
to to appoint this nifty little piece
the problem here for the Security
Council it seems to me is that today
it's on all three of these areas the
council is dealing with the human
interests a human rights protection
issues humanitarian and heavily with
DeMint democratic practices State
Building and the rest and much more so
in the last ten years or so it's quite
heavily involved in the middle kinds of
issues
somatic issues in many ways and more so
particularly in recent years including
in the environment issues of this sort
and of course a number of the core
national interests now are coming before
the the council light like terrorism and
WMD non-proliferation these kinds of
issues so in a way this is all good news
and it's among the reasons why the
council is so active it's trying to do
everything in all these areas the
problem is the national commitment to
back these up varies enormous ly from
one area to the other and therefore the
council ends up with a very mottled kind
of an agenda agenda and very very uneven
performance
it looks like groups is trying to be all
things to all people when it deals with
many of the issues in the middle
it's accused of encroachment Beasley the
General Assembly and as it defines
security broader and broader this tends
to be
a very difficult problem for it it gets
involved in a lot of issues here that it
doesn't have much control over and it
doesn't have the the institutional
capacity to deal with very effectively
and those on the right non perforation
counterterrorism tend to be rather
controversial among than understates the
big powers tend to favor them at least
the western big fire powers and some of
the others are rather worried so you
have a very difficult problem sort of
the image of the council it's not just
peacekeeping anymore it's a lot of
different kinds of things now the second
problem that I see with the council
these days is what I'd call the tip of
the iceberg problem
what we see is that group meeting around
the horse strip table in the security
council chamber we tend to focus on the
15 we tend to focus on the resolutions
and what we don't see is all of the
growing bureaucracy the growing
institutionalization under that in the
council let me skip here a couple that's
what I ordered here we are subsidiary
bodies of the Security Council now
depending how you count the
approximately 28 at this moment almost
all of them are chaired by non-permanent
members rarely does a permanent member
chair any of these so on the one hand it
gives the 1090 members a lot of stuff to
do and some of it's relatively important
stuff on the other hand they feel
they're so tied up running all these
working groups and committees that they
don't have they're spread very thin and
it's all sort of a ruse to make sure
that they don't have much influence on
the council but these are not some of
these unimportant activities on the part
of the on the part of the council you
see these on sanctions and similar
matters we still have a dozen of those
it changes obviously when the sanction
regime is lifted but each new sanction
regime
normally has its own count its own
committee and the committee's normally
operate by consensus so it's one nation
one vote so the good news is that
everyone's got a veto you know not only
five it's it's it's a an equity you have
15 countries with vetoes so of course
it's very hard to to move along on many
of these people sometimes forget that
the ad hoc tribunals are under the
council Yugoslavia Rwanda whatever and
there's a lot of working groups and many
of these working groups deal with
thematic kinds of issues and sometimes
trouble the countries in the in the
assembly because of encroaching now what
you have is a number of these
particularly goals on counterterrorism
have their own staffs which are not well
integrated into the regular Secretariat
and so the Security Council not only has
these 28 subsidiary bodies many of them
have their own experts groups many have
their own regular staff and they're
there the functions are spread around
the organization and all the way from
Vienna to Geneva at 2 to New York okay
so you've got a growing bureaucracy and
you have no real history or
institutional arrangements for handling
a growing bureaucracy
now forth not unrelated to that the
council really has become an operational
body in many ways operating in the field
itself the council on a fairly regular
basis now takes missions out to the
field as you're all will remember from
the Charter the council doesn't have to
meet in New York all the time so
sometimes meets in other places it has
its own staff and going out to various
places to see what's going on
and very often subgroups of the council
will go out as well in addition there
are a lot of new tools as part of this
questions of reporting questions of of
setting up various kind of monitoring
mechanisms under the council itself so
it's changing from a group that sort of
sits around a table and votes to the
group that's very actively involved in
the running of the UN's field operations
in and of themselves
now finally the fifth one I'm going to
spend some time on this one is a
question of sovereignty now to me this
is not an insurmountable problem and it
frankly has not been for the councillor
as it goes about its work but over time
as the council's work becomes more and
more intrusive more and more operational
it is something that causes a pause for
a lot of member states now if you look
at the Charter there's a lot of things
assigned to the organisation that are
inherently very intrusive that can't be
solved simply through international
negotiation and some of these are given
to the council to deal with even under
the Charter you're all of course have
memorised article 34 article 34 of the
Charter gives the council the right and
responsibility to investigate including
within States matters which it deems not
necessarily a threat to international
peace and security or any breach of
security
instead things that might lead to
trouble that might lead eventually to
something that they might have to look
at under Chapter 7 there elsewhere it's
really a wide-open the way it's written
under 34 so now the counts are going out
to the field and doing investigations
and whatever really is very consistent
with article 34 though it's rarely it's
rarely cited you look at issues such as
counterterrorism how do you deal with
counterterrorism in a way that's not
intrusive now 1373
the unanimous resolution two and a half
weeks after 9/11 is rather sweeping and
there is some pushback on it
dealing first and foremost with the
financing of terrorism but also the
movement of terrorists the sheltering of
terrorists aiding and abetting one way
and or the other and again it's asking
Member States to report and
when they report to get evaluated and
then they asked report again and then
other groups like 15:40 on weapons of
mass destruction and terrorism again
reporting and what are you doing to try
to improve your efforts a lot the
council is very deeply involved in now
on capacity-building within states for
example what are you doing in terms of
legislation to deal with terrorism and
non-proliferation what are you doing
with policing your borders what are you
doing in terms of the flow of money and
interacting the flow of money and so the
council is getting involved in order to
try to deal with with terrorism
obviously in a preventive fashion and
not after the fact in a way which is
inherently intrusive the same is
obviously true with non-proliferation
how do you deal with the threat of the
acquisition of nuclear biological or
chemical weapons if you're not intrusive
each of those three conventions run out
obviously council conventions refer back
one way or the other to the council
ultimately forward for enforcement
purposes and finally we have the whole
humanitarian area and the responsibility
to protect this one obviously I feel
fairly passionate about and I think the
good news is that the secretary-general
does as well now I always assumed that
states were formed and I think I learned
some of that in this class in part to
provide protection to people people
groups tribes whatever would come
together in some kind of a collective
for their their collective security that
this was a fundamental purpose of the
state and that over time states have
been quite ready to see their
sovereignty and hundreds of ways all the
time we see very few complaints from
states that in the development efforts
of the UN are infringing upon their
sovereignty now then you have complaints
but by and large they welcome that you
see very few complaints to trade
relationships are infringing upon one's
sovereignty yet clearly they do
particularly these trade plus kinds of
kinds of relationships that we have now
big state small states they all sign
thousands and thousands of agreements
with other states
if sovereignty is the freedom of choice
each of these in some ways impinge upon
your freedom of choice and the state
makes the choice that they're better off
by doing this so not doing this I mean
quite frankly if you look at the
services the states are required to be
viable these be their citizens very few
of them can the state man any state
managed on its own there's something
that I would call the sovereignty gap
the gap between what states are required
to do simply to be viable visa vie their
citizens and then visa be the
responsibilities of statehood and what
they can deliver on their own most of
the things the states have to deliver
they need cooperation of other states
one way the other what can you do about
environmental issues if you don't deal
with neighbors and others what can you
do about disease if you don't deal with
neighbors what do you do about narco
trafficking what do you do about
organized crime what do you do about
finance and commerce what do you do
about security I mean no state is secure
without the cooperation of others and
when you live in an era of nuclear
weapons you live in an era of
intercontinental continental delivery
you live in an era of terrorism how can
you say that you are a target in terms
of security so it really is only a
question of where you seek your
sovereignty and it's always been my
feeling that what international
organizations do and some extent
international law as well is to allow
the internet in your state system to
survive
international organizations are not the
enemy of sovereignty they're what allows
R&D to persist they're not the enemies
of States they're the Friends of States
the Secretary General has argued at
various points that the UN is highly
dependent on having strong independent
states because the UN international
institutions cannot be effective they
don't have the capacity unless the
states within them are strong and
independent the problems that the UN
faces constantly are with weak states or
failing States and they take up in
amount of time of the organization and
so the strength of states is not an
enemy in my view and sovereignty is not
an enemy to effective international
organization in fact it's a requirement
for it
just as the interstate system can't
survive unless you have effective
international law and organization and
it seems to me even very strong states
come to understand that and the very
weak of states are those that have not
learned to understand that you looked at
the North Korea's the Myanmar's of the
world they're not very many of them
their states have tried to be relatively
art arctic and you look at them compared
to all of their neighbors they're not
going in the same direction so to say
that sovereignty is somehow all of a
sudden the barrier when it comes to
human rights and humanitarian a
treatment of populations seems to me is
extraordinarily artificial and that in
fact many of the treat many of the
countries who raise these questions have
long been parties to any number of human
rights conventions so in recent years
this has been put in different ways
obviously coffee and on particularly in
9899 gave a number of very important
speeches about humanitarian intervention
and the dilemma about whether it's
better to sit by or whether it's better
to move forward including the military
terms even if you do not have unanimity
in the council or at least the necessary
nine votes and the votes of the five is
a Kosovo poacher or not in essence in
that kind of regard and what do you do
if you have another Rwanda but Rwanda
happens to be on the council and there
happen to be one or two big states that
don't want to move
is it the moral thing to do is that the
legal thing to do is it the appropriate
thing to do to stand by while one by one
rates now a couple of years ago as many
of you I'm sure have seen the Canadians
put together and print a Jeanette the
report put together the International
Commission Commission and intervention
and and state sovereignty I'm sure many
of you are very very familiar with it
I'd like to
run through a couple of their
recommendations and raise some questions
about them talk very briefly about the
outcome document of the global summit of
two years ago which then accepted the
responsibility to protect now principles
for military intervention now most of
these are drawn from the Just War
Doctrine most of these are not terribly
new and most of these are not terribly
controversial but I think some of these
things are are worth asking some
questions about the very first one on
the Just Cause threshold it refers to
serious and irreparable harm I don't
think that's a legal standard and they
were occurring - human beings are
imminently likely to are curved one of
the biggest problems is how do we know
what's imminently likely to occur and if
it's that imminent is it too late to
really do preventive action to begin
with it's going to happen tomorrow maybe
we've missed the the vote under that
this point a large-scale loss of life
actual apprehended well have we had
major Wars or civil wars that didn't
have a large-scale loss of life is that
a useful standard or not again these are
not legal legal standards the question
of neglect the question of failure to
act even if it is not intentional the
suggestion here is that state neglect
our inability to act or a failed state
situation is sufficient justification
for the international community to act
again something that's not so easy to do
and sort out in practice now the
precautionary principles these are
clearly the Just War doctrine in a new
guys
the first one right intention I guess
it's better than wrong then it's better
than wrong intention whether it's better
than left intention I guess is is is a
political question but in any case right
intention is better assured with
multilateral operations that's probably
true but does it actually coincide with
military realities in terms of
effectiveness our model at our
operations usually more effective
actually on the ground or not and now if
it's a peace operation and in a static
situation probably for political reasons
it makes good sense but if you actually
intervene to protect people in a time of
imminent danger in the time of conflict
his model and realism always avert your
other than the political correctness of
it I look at Dartford
right now now the Sudanese government
has taken the politically correct
position which is that the peacekeepers
ought to be ought to be all African this
is an African situation after all we
don't want countries from the north that
might have the bias of one sort or
another to send their soldiers but also
it might be that the politically correct
solution is in part because the AU
force will not have any attack
helicopters or other means of moving
quickly from place to place and as we've
seen recently are often victims
themselves in some of these cases so you
know one might ask yes right intention
is great mono violet multilateralism is
great but is it already effective now
the second one last resort I must say
gives me some some pause as I say this
is a as a college professor not as a
sometime advisor at the UN because I'm
not sure this is exactly my position be
a UN position but for the sake of
academic argument let's look at last
resort military intervention can only be
justified when every non-military option
has been explored what does that mean
every other option has been explored now
if I was a perpetrator on the other side
and I saw that the intent of those who
might do something about this
what
look at absolutely every other option
they could possibly imagine
and if nothing works and everything has
been exhausted then yeah then we might
think of getting tough well you know one
I think I have a lot of time to do what
I wanted to do get rid of people I
wanted to get rid of and whatever and
two I think I would question the
commitment of those who might get
involved and quite frankly is this
consistent with the UN Charter I would
argue it's not no many secretaries
general have said that the use of force
should always be the last resort so it's
almost gospel in the institution so this
is only an academic opinion of course
but if you look back at San Francisco
there was a debate about article 42 on
the use of force and the debate wasn't
that it was going to be too often and
too rapid but quite the opposite that it
wasn't going to happen and who wanted
the wording of the Charter and 42 to be
more open to military action it wasn't
the big military powers in fact the
draft produced by the US and and and put
forward from from Dumbarton Oaks
actually said that military force would
be used when other measures as in 41 on
sanctions have proved to be inadequate
so the u.s. went sort of half way
towards this you know last resort there
was a Canadians you know the warlike
Canadians big dominant superpower that
came and said no no no wait a minute
this is not what many of us want we need
to know that the council is going to be
there when we need it to be and so they
suggested that the words be added that
the council considers that article 41
measures would be or have proved to be
inadequate so the council can make the
judgement that down the road other
things are not going to be enough so we
have to act more and more rapidly okay
now point C proportional means and we
helped you be against proportional means
of course we should be proportional you
know I'm not going to argue for
disproportionate means
he started fun too but I don't think it
probably would be the best best best
argument
so let me instead look at the wording
here the scale duration and intensity of
the planned military intervention should
be the minimum necessary okay why not
but how do you know what's going to be
the minimum necessary now military
planning traditionally has been based on
worst-case reasoning or something close
to it sometimes it may get us in trouble
but the assumption is you should have
some redundancy because you don't know
what is the minimum necessary you don't
know when things could escalate you
don't know when things to grow badly you
don't know when things aren't going to
work out the way that you want and in
fact I would argue that very often in
historically the greater and and more
decisive use of force has actually saved
lives particularly civilian lives now
it's not always true obviously depends
how and how you use force but if you're
doing it step by step by step by step
maybe one it gives the other side time
to react and to it doesn't work so well
in terms of convincing them of your
seriousness and we see places I hate to
mention Iraq now yes I don't think many
people in this room thought that we
should have gone in Iraq and I didn't
think we should have either militarily
but if one was to do it it probably
would have made sense to do it with a
lot larger force to prevent a lot of the
things that have happened since that
time and that going in with the minimum
necessary actually was was much more the
point of view of the Secretary of
Defense who now rethink perhaps had it
wrong okay third what about the show of
force not really anything here about the
show of force somehow threatening the
use of force what about a deterrent you
know maybe if you have an effective
deterrent you don't actually have to use
it at all where does deterrence fit
under this I don't know I don't think
saying that if we have to his last
resort use the minimum
you know is really a very effective
deterrent because you're just convincing
them that you're not serious about going
forward so you know I think there are
maybe humanitarian cases where you could
have a display of force the threat of
force a show of force which might might
make some difference to the parties in
that regard what about a preventive
deployment you know you see things are
starting to go the wrong direction one
way or the other and you put some forces
in the preventive mode now it's been
done a couple of times not in the
humanitarian situation but in in
Macedonia for example and it worked
quite well now finally I think it's
worth noting that again I don't think
that a this is contrary to the Charter
and NC but none of this kind of wording
is in the Charter nowhere where you find
the minimum proportion oh you know
reasonable step by step any that sort of
thing because those countries had just
come from war and smaller countries
particular those that have been overrun
wanted to be sure that this council
would be as quick to respond as possible
which is among the reasons why they
objected to the veto they objected the
veto in part because it was inequitable
but primarily because it was going to
make it harder for the council respond
they had less reason to be assured that
multilateral action might actually be
there okay now let's go on to the next
one on on write authority there's no
better or more appropriate body than the
United Nations Security Council to
authorize military intervention for
human protection purposes I mean I don't
lease I couldn't disagree with that but
it's interesting when this these same
sets of principles are taken up by the
high-level panel that the
secretary-general had set up on
challenges and threats challenges and
change it was tied to a what proved to
be an unattainable expansion of the
Security Council the argument the
Security Council was not legitimate
unless it was larger and had a new cast
of characters added to it and also
asking the p5 to pledge not to use their
veto in the case of humanitarian
emergencies so on the one hand they say
okay the council is the best body
but we really started out its its
legitimacy now under be the
secretary-general on article 99 again no
problem with that
but we should remember that it's very
very rarely used in parts of the
secretary-general doesn't really have to
use it because accounts are already
surprised of all these kinds of things
and there's no ongoing dialogue between
the Secretariat and the council now
principles point be again that the five
should not use their veto power in these
kinds of cases fine is I think argued in
my piece that you may or may not have
read you know the council has never
accepted any guidelines any standard for
its decisions there are a lot of
discussions in San Francisco about this
they're all rejected the council was to
be a political body among other things
it was not to defend or enforce any
particular treaty provisions they were
all left outside the council was to
decide in political basis when and how
it was going to use its powers under
Chapter 7 and it's interesting when in
the summit two years ago the the largest
gathering of heads of state and
government history when the r2p
paragraphs which we looked at in a
minute were adopted the last state to
come aboard was India and what some of
them some of the Indian diplomats have
said to me is look we're great friends
to r2p and humanitarian protection but
we don't think it should be done unless
there's a restriction on the use of the
veto it might have been a mere
coincidence that at the same time it was
trying to get a permanent seat on the
council and that these issues all got
tied up together but I don't think we're
going to see them to read it assume but
it would be a nice thing if they would
subsequent authorization from the
Security Council that obviously is
contrary to article 53 when such
authorization has to be sought
beforehand now finally an in-point F
there it seems to me it's somewhat less
than a legal term responsibility to
protect in conscience shocking
situations crying out for action
you know that sounds like a media
definition you know if if we're really
shocked and if we happen to see it on TV
then we should act if the cameras aren't
there and therefore consciousness is not
there therefore we don't need to and
just one final point under operational
principle is the Point C acceptance of
limitations incremental ISM and
gradualism in the application of force
again I think that only is giving those
committing atrocity more time and less
less to worry about
now what do they do at the with the
outcome document they got here somewhere
there you go
okay two paragraphs on r2p now some
people call it rqp light because of the
caveats in it but I think is actually
not not a bad basis on which to act now
here you know they're not talking about
consciousness-raising or anything of
this sort they're talking about four
kinds of crimes protect population
genocide war crimes ethnic cleansing and
crimes against humanity
nothing about suffering serious harm
nothing about our being shocked about it
or anything of this sort for crimes
now ethnic cleansing is not well
established an international law the
others are war crimes quite frankly it
could be a little problematic you know
an individual act by a soldier somewhere
that could be a little bit tough
genocide very well established obviously
in international law crimes against
humanity well established as well now
paragraph 138 in some ways it restates
what countries have signed up for under
human rights treaties but I think it's
important the way it's it's it's it's
put one it stresses prevention to it
includes incitement incitement is also
not allowed very important and then the
the critical sentence in the middle of
138 there we accept that responsibility
and will act in accordance with it so
the pledge at least is unambiguous the
action obviously may be something less
and then the international community
should encourage and help states to
exercise responsibility
sparked the UN and establishing early
warning capability as far as I can
recall
I only remember about 3035 years of
discussion establishing effective early
warning so it's been around a little
while but nevertheless this goes on a
bit more
now 139 most people point to is what is
really rather new then not only does the
individual state have the responsibility
but the international community also has
responsibility the international
community obviously is not party to
these various conventions it has
responsibilities both under six and
eight diplomatic humanitarian peaceful
means to protect populations and this is
the pledge a second pledge in this
context we were prepared to take
collective action and timely decisive
manner through the Security Council in
accordance with the Charter including
chapter 7 case by case successor
exception should peaceful means be an
adequate sort of a not quite 42 but
something don't like it and national
authorities manifestly fail to protect
their populations from these four crimes
and then it goes on about the General
Assembly and importantly at the bottom
of the helping states build a capacity
to protect and to assist those that are
under stress because for crises and
conflicts break out no this is not
everything that one might have wanted
but it seems to me it goes a very long
way and it provides some very
interesting openings including openings
to sovereignty
how do you do capacity building without
doing it in a very intrusive kind of the
way how do you go in and assist States
on questions like incitement how do you
help States built in the barriers so
they don't take these kinds of paths in
the last two years since this document
was was accepted by all the heads of
state and government there's been a lot
of backsliding there's been some buyer's
remorse on the part of some states as if
they didn't know what they were signing
up for
it's worth remembering of that regard
one that other Vaught very long
difficult
negotiations that led to this and also
that important parts of this outcome
document were dropped out entirely
because they couldn't find agreement all
the stuff and disarmament
non-proliferation etc bra dropped out of
it so the fact that this survived I
think is in of itself quite significant
and unfortunately much of the debate
publicly in the last two years has been
about the use of force even the emphasis
by the International Commission on rules
for the use of force made it sound as if
our duty was all about the use of force
even though the report itself had a lot
of good things to say about prevention
and so that was was step number one so
now we have to figure out I guess this
is where I'm supposed to take the lead
and how one implements this in part how
does one rebuild member state support -
how does one straighten out the
conceptual side about what r2p doesn't
does that mean you know some people said
it should be about everything from
global warming to to hiv/aids
to rights of indigenous people and one
thing another and it seems to me the
outcome document tells us it's about
four sets of crimes it's not about a lot
of other terrible things that happen in
the world second of all we're gonna work
very hard on the side of prevention the
side of capacity-building I'll see where
that takes us
and see what what lessons can be learned
from past genocides and in s atrocities
and eventually over time and get to the
more coercive or coercive end of this
now in all of this just to conclude I
think it's worth remembering that this
really is all historical process and
we're just at some point in this each
time you take a step forward two steps
forward it's one step back two steps
back coffee and on pushed on
humanitarian intervention and in 99 98
I had his culminating speech to the
General Assembly in September 1999 had
sort of mixed reviews and retreated he
looked at his millennium Millennium
report the next year a largely drafted
by a former dean John Ruggie it has
hardly anything to say on the subject
where the secretary Eric John had been
very bold he then pulled back then the
ISIS panel raised it up again and then
it was picked up by the high-level panel
and eventually by the by the by the
World Summit and again we've had two
years of retreat now we have a new
Secretary General who was made pledges
in his campaign about trying to
operationalize this and I was very bound
and determined to do so so we move back
we move forward but I think in the end
if you looked at 10 years 20 years 30
years clearly the direction is very
clear and I think there's reasons why
some of the conservatives in this
country and elsewhere have been very
reactive and very negative on much of
the advance of international law and
organization because they see it as
almost inevitable they see it as having
tremendous political momentum and
potentially over time really tying the
hands of the powerful in many ways
really embedding countries in a network
of law and network of cooperation
network of institutions that in fact is
so compelling in many ways that there's
no retreat and no stepping back so
there's pushback but in the in the end
it seems to me the direction is very
very clear it's difficult obviously when
you have institution like the Security
Council they're unable to reform
themselves or the Health Assembly or
others reform them but it does seem to
me even there it's a very very dynamic
institution that's changing both what it
does and how it does it in many in many
encouraging kinds of ways so I hope
that's enough at least to generate a
little bit of conversation and I
appreciate your comments questions and
critiques and I appreciate that the mic
worked for a while thank you